okay let's try one more bot
just to wrap this one up and
who shall we try this time
okay let's try
let's try danny let's see what happens there
uh
oh danny benoni nope bloom inside
i'm not completely sure this is
how i wanted to play this but
okay at least my bishop gets
out there okay let's castle
let's take that one i feel better after this move
ah danny boy
hmm
i think danny is a bit confused about
exchanging material when you're down and up that's
what i reckon um probably i should just get an e4
but you always have the feeling you'll
be cheaper somehow after that okay what
i once saw dany play what was it one minute chess
with maxine outside there in central louise and
that was fun i have to admit that was good fun
okay come on we should do a good
technique here just swap the bishops now
and bring some rooks over to the center
okay that's nice so now i can do this
ah tricky
and let's give a
check
and then
very safe h3 and all that oh i'm full of
technique here but danny missed another trick
okay and how do we do this should i double
should i go knight g4 another rook d4
wait can i go rook d2 yes i can so i mean
if you get a cheaper you should make it
okay let's see how that ends oh come on what is
wrong with me i completely forgot about that one
wait i've got a i've got a couple of things up
my sleeve so i should be okay let's take that one
let's take that one and let's go there
and then what's he gonna do knight f4
okay i think i can take that one
okay this must be another cheapo somewhere
in the air but he's still got the back rank
so i can max this pawn out get it as
far as possible okay let's do that
and let's do that okay so let's go there
and then like the best technicians of your
let's now silently advance that form h5
okay let's do g3
king g2
i think is what they all say the great technical
players never rush probably i might be overdoing
it but anyway okay if i play a6 he's gonna go what
knight d5 and let's try it and my big trick haha
okay
you were testing me dany i
thought i was testing you
anyway i uh i think you can have a
lot of fun these um bots seem to have
some personality it's hard to tell how much
they're as tricky as computers but not so much
that they snuffed the life out of you and
i think it is it's good to play against
something that will make a lot of mistakes but
still play tactically accurately and
it's definitely a very nice training tool
so um yeah i hope you enjoyed these and there are
many many more bots i should do maurice next time
but i'm going to
sign off for now i'm relieved to have
saved it against myself it was nice that
my bot has no clue how to win a rook ending
just like me and yeah i hope you had fun